so let's reset the real story here with
Trump and Ukraine is the whistleblower
complaint all along we had reports of
what was believed to be in the complaint
news of the suppression of the complaint
Donald Trump saying he would release a
transcript but then releasing a summary
the Democrat decision the Democrats a
decision I don't want to fall into that
a right-wing meme of saying Democrat the
decision made by Democrats to start an
impeachment inquiry against Donald Trump
we'd all this stuff swirling but really
at the core the whistleblower complaint
is the thing here we now have the
complaint and arguably the most stunning
revelation about what's in the report
that we didn't already know which has
now been Declassified is that the
complaint says not only was there a
planned and proactive pattern of
obfuscation around the phone call
between Donald Trump and the Ukrainian
president but it specifically says that
Trump administration officials have
moved records of Donald Trump's
conversations with foreign officials
including this July 25 phone call to a
separate computer network or server than
where these are habitually stored now
the exact details we don't yet know is
it are we talking about a private server
reminiscent of what Hillary Clinton was
criticized for doing are we talking
about we don't know the exact technical
specifications of what was done but
specifically the whistleblower says the
July 25 phone call with the Ukrainian
president which is at issue here was one
of those calls that was moved this
alarmed an intelligence community
Inspector to tell the White House you've
got to keep these records and you've got
to keep them in the normal way and
remember we were told this was why
Hillary couldn't be trusted
emails on private servers and here is
Donald Trump allegedly moving records of
communications with world leaders
particularly incriminating records to
some other computer system or some other
server farm or we don't even know
exactly where it was moved to at this
point in time Democrats of course even
in advance of the complaint going public
who were shown the whistleblower
complaint are going crazy Adam Schiff
saying it is deeply disturbing and
deeply credible congressman Mike
quigley saying it is troubling and
disturbing Eric's wall well saying that
it invokes other witnesses to the
disturbing conduct referencing of course
White House lawyers White House
officials involved in the moving of
these electronic records Republicans not
surprisingly are saying they're not
concerned at all about the content of
the report and I don't think that should
surprise any of us in the same way that
it should not surprise us that they
aren't going to vote no matter what the
House of Representatives finds to indict
to convict and remove Donald Trump from
the presidency if they're just not
participating in any of this other than
Justin Amash oh I guess it's not even a
Republican anymore understand what's
going on here and he's a congressman not
not a senator understand what's going on
here the White House is moving the
conversations that it wants to hide to
some other computer system or server and
in a sense this may be useful to us
because we can just look at what did
they move off of the official server to
help us figure out which are the
conversations that are most damaging to
Trump but of course the problem is are
we ever going to get access to those
conversations or even though we now know
or have reason to believe that there is
another server another computer system
is that going to also prevent us from
getting access to the contents of that
system because the whole point here is
they know what they are doing
they are moving the record of a call
which could be a recording and or the
full transcript we know the full
transcript exists we don't know if the
recording exists but presumably it might
they know that it is damaging and
therefore they are moving it when asked
for the record when you say oh all we
have on official White House computers
is this truncated bogus summary rather
than an actual transcript sorry the
whole point is to pretend nothing else
exists we now at least have credible
reason to believe there is a full
transcript of the phone call if not a
recording it's more and more like the
Nixon tapes the question is will we ever
get access to it now I almost wanted to
delay production of the show today
because things are moving so quickly and
we did delay production somewhat there
maybe even krei
your news by the time we get today's
program edited and published so I
apologize in advance if we know even
more than what I just told you about the
complaint and the context and the moving
of the electronic records it's all what
we know now I've told you it's all of
course very legal and very cool
according to Donald Trump but as far as
the whistleblower goes once again I hope
they are able to maintain their
anonymity which they want by the time
you watch this clip or listen to today's
podcast then the name and information of
the whistleblower may have gone public I
fear for the threats that this
individual will get from trumpets if
their identity becomes known it's
something I wouldn't wish on my worst
enemy so hopefully they are able to
maintain anonymity let me know what you
think about the contents of the
whistleblower complaint I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show I hope you will follow
both accounts and so much more to
discuss today upcoming I want to tell
you about one of our sponsors called the
Menlo Club a men's fashion community
that provides carefully curated style
packages for any type of guy and they're
giving you as a David Pakman show viewer
your first box for $35 off when you
click the link underneath this video or
go to their site and use the promo code
Pakman as a member of the Menlo Club you
receive delivered right to your door a
hand-picked apparel package that follows
the seasons latest trends based on your
own unique style profile I hate shopping
for clothes it's always been a pain to
go to a store figure out what to buy and
that's why the Menlo Club is so perfect
for me all I had to do was fill out a
quiz on their website so they could
learn my sizes and style preferences and
then I received clothes that perfectly
fit my own personal style so far I've
really enjoyed what they've sent me all
of their clothing is designed by their
team in Los Angeles
each box features items from their own
in-house fashion brands 5 for everyday
wear New Republic Footwear and Grande
see athleisure wear in every box they
send you you get a minimum of 2 items
often more every box is different
is always free and they let you exchange
what you get if it doesn't fit you can
pause or cancel your subscription at any
time right now I am on their monthly
subscription for 60 bucks a month but
they also offer a seasonal subscription
where they send you a box of clothing
every three months for just 75 bucks but
regardless of which option you choose
they are giving everyone in our audience
$35 off their first box to redeem your
$35 discount just click the link under
this video or go to their website and
use the promo code Pakman at checkout